to present the scientific and technical
awards here are Barbara Rush and Jacques
Tati mr. Tati is famed in this country
is mr. Hugh lot of mr. Hugh lots holiday
but it is in addition to being a star he
also writes his own pictures directs
them and produces them just think one
man has eliminated three agents here
they are
because of the complexity of a language
with which Monsieur Tati is not too
familiar I have been asked to read the
following is that alright with you
talking a class to award to Don W pedo
Roy Layton and the lamp division of
General Electric Company for the
development and production of an
improved 10 kilowatt lamp for motion
picture set lighting
a class to award to Panavision
incorporated for the design and
development of the Auto panatar Canada
panatar anamorphic photographic lens
element mr. robert Gottschalk will
accept for Panavision
we have Panavision a class three award
has been voted to Willie Warburg of the
general precision laboratory
incorporated for the development of a
high-speed intermittent movement for
thirty five-millimeter motion picture
theater projection equipment and to Fred
Pond Adele George Brown Hana Delta no
tsunami we and to Fred upon Adelle
George Brown and Conrad boy of the
Warner Brothers special effects
Department for the design and
fabrication of a new rapid-fire bullet
simulating gun congratulations gentlemen
mr. toffee city Feeny we it's why they
bringing the all the way from Paris